- On this episode Casey stops by.
Again.
(hip hop music)
You ask questions.
And I answer them.
This is
The #AskGaryVee Show.
- You know I think it was
like 122 or something.
We had the same count on your show
and on my show the same day.
- Are you serious?
- Yeah, it was like the moons
aligned for a minute, Gary.
(laughs)
- Did videos explode?
- Yeah, I mean...
- Case, tell the Vayner Nation
for the one or two people
that don't know who you are.
This is a first time,
second time guest appearance.
And we've only had like
three guests ever.
So clearly, I like you a lot, Case.
- Thanks, man. I mean,
it's great to be here.
Who am I? I make videos.
I have a technology company.
And I'm a huge admirer of you, Gary.
And this wonderful show
that you've been putting
out there for all of us viewers.
- I appreciate it.
So, I think we'll just get right into it.
I think we had a lot
of questions yesterday.
Kinda tweeted out that you'd be here
and people got excited.
You have a new startup.
Which we'll give some time, I'd like you
to talk about it for a few minutes.
- Great.
- But India.
That's why I went on the left side.
- I know. (laughs)
- Let's...
Get into...
The show. (laughs)
Not bad, you are getting better.
I'm gonna have to find some new ticks
to throw you off.
India let's get into it.
- [Voiceover] Lucy asks,
"At the age of 18, what's the
best way to approach a company
"and ask for work experience?"
- Wait--
- Ask for an internship?
- You ask for work?
Don't you just ask for work?
- [India] I guess because a lot people
come to companies and it says like
you need this many years of experience.
- Oh, I see.
- [Gary] I see.
- [India] But how do
you get that experience
if nobody wants to hire
you because everybody--
- When you're 18.
- [India] Yeah.
- I got an answer to this, I mean
I think that we now live in a world--
Casey, how many people,
how many people hit you
up on Twitter, email,
other platforms, comments and YouTube,
you must have a gadrillion.
How many times have you in your career--
When would you say that
you started really building
into a place where people
were really pinging you?
Is this now a two, three,
four year phenomenon for you?
- For work?
- Yes.
Not for work, more like
people that are fans of you,
clearly at this point.
- It's been a long time.
- How long, do you think?
- I mean, I think since the
first video I made went viral
over 10 years ago.
- Got it. So, it's been pretty
consistent since then?
- Yeah.
- Good,
how many times have you
randomly done stuff?
Yes, met someone, got on a phone.
How many times?
- Now, if I could count that, Gary.
More than I could ever keep track of.
- That's your answer.
Who was the question?
- [India] Lucy.
- Lucy that's your answer.
I also--
The majority of this entire team
is based on random shit.
Like so, I think you just ask
as many times as possible.
There are unlimited companies
in a world you can get
to almost anybody because of Twitter,
again, a true social network.
More so than comments on content
which a lot of other platforms are.
Email, at this point, I
think has been played out.
It's harder to get to
people through email.
But that will still work too.
I think it's stunning that you can get
to most people in the world today.
I don't think people,
as many people are as wired as you and I.
I think people have drawn the line to no
but there's plenty.
We're not the only two nice guys
believing in serendipity.
There are tens of thousands
wildly accomplished
CEOs, co-founders, that
will absolutely hire you
on spec from one
request to get experience
whether they give you an internship
or pay you minimum wage
or even give you a salary.
It is a wide open field.
It's about asking.
- Yeah, I mean, I would
even complement what,
everything Gary just said,
I'd complement that, Lucy
by saying, you also have an
opportunity via these myriad
social outlets and the
internet as a whole.
Not just to reach out and contact people
but to actually prove yourself.
Like, if you need to show this experience
that these people are seeking after,
just do it.
You don't need someone's
permission to do that.
If you wanna work in
construction, build something.
an automotive factory,
work on cars.
If you wanna be a filmmaker, make videos.
You now have these multitude
of options in front of you
to show that you're capable.
If you wanna be a writer, write something.
- You know what happens
in that environment?
If you actually have it,
not everybody has it.
But if you actually have it,
you start getting into
a place very quickly
that you realize, oh wait,
I don't need to have a job
in the first place. (laughs)
- That's right,
no longer do you need the
runway to prove your worth on.
You don't need someone else's approval,
you just do it yourself.
Scary and very hard to do,
it's not to be underestimated
just how challenging that is
but it doesn't mean that
the opportunity isn't there
and that opportunity wasn't
there 10, 15 years ago.
But it's uniquely there now.
- We're byproducts of that game.
- My entire career is
product of that game.
- I had a liquor store
in New Jersey and got
300 dollar camera at Best Buy
and decided to make wine videos
because I wanted to be like Emeril.
- Wine videos.
India, let's move it.
Oh, by the way, I didn't get
weird there out of nowhere.
We are streaming on
Facebook live right now.
Be interesting to see--
It's a whole different
dynamic 'cause these shows
are consumed so much on Facebook live
which launched yesterday.
India?
- [Voiceover] Benjamin asks,
"Where does confidence come from?
"How do you both work on it?"
- That's tough.
- I'll let you go first here.
(laughs)
- Confidence, I mean--
- Hold on.
- [Voiceover] That's awesome.
- Yeah, I couldn't (laughs)
- You didn't know the address?
- Gary, over your left shoulder
is my electric skateboard.
Right there.
- Yes.
- I rode that electric skateboard up here.
And if there's one thing you
don't wanna do while traveling
24 miles an hour in heavy
traffic through New York City,
on an electric skateboard
is to whip out your phone
and double check an address.
- Respect.
- So you gotta write that down.
All right, answer Ben's question
about your outrageous level
How does one have enough
confidence to ride
an electronic skateboard 24
miles an hour in New York City?
- I have an answer that's
not really a great one
for people to hear, so I'm hoping you have
a better answer than I do, Gary.
My answer goes like this,
I'm one of four kids.
There was the first born.
The only daughter.
And the baby.
And then there's the
forgotten child, Casey.
So in my household, it
was like fight to survive.
And my confidence was like born into me
out of need to just exist
and be noticed and be fed.
Now, not everyone has had
the beautiful misfortune
that yielded the fortune of my childhood
that turned me into a confident person.
But I think it's very
different from someone who
finds themselves, as an
adult, in a world that sort of
thrives on those who have confidence
and being forced to find
that within yourself.
But one shortcut I found to
that is making something.
Making anything.
Whether that's writing something,
whether it's something creative,
whether it's something more pragmatic.
Whether that's a relationship,
whether that's a friendship.
If you generate something
you can take sort of,
you take comfort in what
it is that you've just made
in your yield and I think
that's a really great shortcut
to finding confidence.
- Casey, answer--
Give me a word association
play really quick here.
Fear.
- Illness.
- Illness?
- Yeah, that's--
- I really didn't want you to go there.
Thanks for screwing up my answer.
(laughs)
For me--
- The only thing, being
sick is the only thing
that I'm scared of.
- By the way,
that's really funny.
Actually, that's really interesting.
Because I was dissing a little bit
and now I'm gonna put you on a pedestal.
It is literally the health and
well-being of the people I--
Weirdly, for me, it's the people I love
is scary ass crap for me.
It's a very big challenge
and we all go through it.
And so, I'm with you on that.
Where I was going with that, is this,
I am not scared to fail,
by any stretch of the imagination.
And it comes in the form of
truly being in this weird place
where I really don't give a
rat's ass what anybody thinks.
And again, that's wiring.
How does one work on that?
What do you think I sit--
What do you think I go in my room like,
"Don't care what anybody thinks.
Don't care what anybody--"
(laughs)
Like, you don't do that.
- Yeah, you get made fun
of a lot in high school
and it seems like the entire
world is falling apart
because you're being picked on.
- I want people to make fun of me.
- You grow up and it
realize it doesn't matter
what other people think.
- I do, India.
- You really don't.
It really doesn't.
And appreciating that--
- It's like those last
two weeks of high school.
If you can capture that feeling.
- Those last two weeks in high school,
literally, everybody stops
caring what anybody thinks
'cause you're all going somewhere else.
And so, I've always had that feeling.
It's crazy how, you know,
I was born with confidence,
I truly believe that.
I do believe, in my case, I
also have the fortunate aspects
of coming from a struggle
place, in a different way.
On the flip side, my mom,
I was the first born.
The apple of my mom's eye.
And so I had massive
positive reinforcement
which then just made me
feel entitled to success.
In an environment where
I was failing classes.
I was 4 foot 11 when I went
into my freshman year of high school.
Not so strong...
- Rough, rough.
-of a situation.
(laughs)
But I walked out--
I mean my book bag was bigger.
Where's you big book bag?
- Didn't bring it today,
not on the skateboard, Gary.
- Like, I literally--
My book bag was like your size.
Let me tell you story
about my freshman year.
Ninth day of school, I'm
walking down the hallway.
I'm late for a class.
I have a Jordache book bag
(laughs)
that's twice the size of me.
I'm walking.
It's like eight minutes
after the bell rang,
I'm lost as fuck
'cause we have huge high school,
I have do idea where I am.
This is terrible, right.
There's some dude, hanging out
of class with Paige Parlow
who was one of the hottest
girls in our school.
It eight days into
school, I know who she is.
She's a sophomore, he's a senior.
I'm walking by them.
He goes, "Psst."
I go, (beep).
I go, "Yeah."
He goes, "The nursery
school's over there."
That's
what happened to me.
Do you know what I went through,
what went through my mind?
I said, wait till (beep)
(beep) (beep) face, punk.
(laughs)
Sorry, India.
That's what went through my mind.
And that's just where
I've always been. (laughs)
I know it was a little crude.
- Gary Vaynerchuk, folks.
(laugh)
- All right, let's move on.
(laughs)
- [India] From Allen.
- India's blushing right now.
- I am, but I blush all the time, so.
- [Gary] Andrew's really blushing.
- That was funny, I'm sorry.
(laughs)
- [Voiceover] Allen asks,
"Casey, how will define if
Beme is a success or not,
"if you haven't already?"
- I definitely haven't already.
Beme which is my technology startup.
Here's some context for--
- Link that up DRock,
in the Facebook post,
in the YouTube post.
Let's make sure everyone who watches--
- In fact, we'll put a link
below that if you click on it
we'll automatically unlock Beme for you
and you will automatically
be following Gary.
- Oh.
- You like that?
We're working, it's a new product
we got a new feature--
- Take that (beep) (beep).
(laughs)
- In the history of social networks,
there's maybe been, what,
what would you say?
How many have succeeded, eight?
- Seven.
That is the swimming pool
that we are currently wading around in.
So to call yourself a success
- And I think that we
define that as a success
of like such meaningful scale,
financial stability,
looking like it's gonna
go in the right direction.
- Social impact.
- Impact, for sure.
- To me, that is a success.
And I mean it, when you can
count it on less than two hands
how many companies have succeeded.
It's not just catching a unicorn.
It is the most, the rarest, hardest thing
you could ever hope to accomplish
in the space of technology.
That's what we're trying to do,
so have I considered it a success?
Not even close.
Ask me in four or five years.
- Click the app.
Yeah, I mean look,
to me one can argue that
it's a success right now.
The amount of people that I come across
who are doing other things in their career
that wanna go then make a app
that has the ambition to
win the consumer web game
is extraordinarily high.
The amount that even saw the day of light,
even saw the day of light
with well financed funding.
That's repetitive.
With money.
With all those things going in their way,
is very small.
Then to have that happen on top of which
to have a very smart, you're
a tremendous marketer.
You know, that means a lot to me.
I'm sure you define yourself
in a lot of different ways
but your marketing skills
are very high, I admire them.
The amount of noise and
excitement that was generated
felt amazing to me, then
you gotta back it up.
So, now there's the next challenge.
Now's the tough part.
Is actually making the
product at that level.
- Yeah, I mean some of the--
- Tim?
Are you typing a new, I'm sorry.
Don't do a new one.
If it's done, it's done.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- Cool, all right.
- We just lost our Facebook feed.
- No, no, okay.
- But some,
some of the greatest failures ever were
a gigantic pile, an
aggregate of tiny successes.
So I appreciate everything you just said
and I really hold dear the tiny
successes we've had thus far
- 60 seconds for everybody who's watching
what it is, how you describe in 60.
I know that's tough but--
- What Beme is,
is Beme is a way of sharing via video
the tiny moments you experience in life
and doing it in a way
that's absolutely dynamic
but doesn't interrupt the moment.
And within this 60 second window
I demonstrate to you
exactly how that happens
and it looks like this.
Like right now, I'm capturing
video of this entire set.
Of Gary's beautiful face just like that
and when you hear the noise
(phone beeps)
that means it's been shared
to all of my followers.
That's what Beme is.
- You know what I love?
But you'll never be able to
see what you just shared.
- Well, not until it's live in the network
and everybody else can.
And that's the whole idea.
Is to remove the scrutiny.
It's to remove sort of,
controlling the image of yourself
in life that you put out there.
I'd like to say, Beme is not about sharing
how the world sees you.
It's sharing how you see the world.
- And what's interesting about that is,
what's really happening in social is
platforms are showing who
you want to be to the world.
We are all living in the most
PR'd version of ourselves.
We have 15 year old girls
running around America right now
who are massive growth hackers
who understand the speed
in which likes come in
on an Instagram photo that
took them 17 minutes to take
and then they take it down
within the first 60 seconds
because they don't like the
data that's coming back as fast.
- Right.
- And they reset.
Literally, three hour dynamics
to pull off the one picture
that's gonna capture the moment
of the concert you went to
which is PR at its finest.
It's an interesting dynamic.
- Yeah, we're trying
to get away from that.
Because I think our,
the ethos, the principle behind
this, our mission statement
is to promote understanding
by sharing perspective.
And I think if you can tap into
other people's perspectives,
you get a better idea as to
what the world is around you.
- When I--
I'm an investor.
When I really got excited,
I'm still excited for this moment, is
the thought of like the
first time I go on stage
and Beme to me is so exciting.
Like literally, people
seeing what I get to see
when I give these keynotes
versus watching me
is an exciting moment for me.
- Do you know, and we can
stop talking about Beme
in a second, but last night
a friend of my named Shon,
Shonduras you know him from Snapchat.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Shon Bemed his daughter being born.
- What?
(whistles)
- I mean, my wife and I
watched it this morning in bed
and we were both crying.
I mean it was unbelievable.
It wasn't the yucky stuff
and it wasn't the stuff that
you would deem inappropriate.
But it was his wife in the
chair, in the bed being anxious
and in the next shot he's holding
his beautiful newborn baby girl.
- That's cool.
- And it was such an emotional,
such a real, raw thing.
And that's we're hoping to accomplish.
He didn't think, he just shared.
- Love it.
- Next question.
- [Voiceover] Alex asks,
"What advice would you give
to a high school student
"struggling to decide what to
pursue as a future career?"
- I've got an answer.
Get busy.
Do something, do anything.
And one of my favorite pieces of advice
as to exactly what you should do,
is do something you hate.
Like, I didn't find my
passion for entrepreneuralship
and filmmaking and everything
that I've done in my career.
I didn't find that by doing it.
I found that by scrubbing pots
in a really terrible seafood restaurant.
Because when you spend 50
hours a week scrubbing pots,
it's 50 hours a week you're obsessing
about what you wish you were doing.
Sitting around playing video games
in your parents' sweet house
is the worst way to find
your mission in life.
Do something, staying busy
is a really, really easy path
to find something you truly
wanna invest yourself in.
- I would also then say to recognize
that playing video games in
your parents' sweet house
is probably your outlet
to success in your career.
I would say that your
ultimate strengths and wants
are the quickest gateway drug to upside
once you recognize that there's
something to be done there.
Too many of you, in the world
don't believe that the thing
they like doing the most
has financial upside.
We've drawn a line in the sand,
that the thing we like is what we do when
we have time to do it like.
And the other places to
either make money or get by.
So many people are in the other bucket
are driven by, I'm gonna go into finance
'cause that's where the money is.
Or I just need enough money
and then I'm gonna have
good work-life balance,
I'll be on the softball
team, I'll play video games.
I really believe--
I really believe that somebody
who's watching this right now
who obsesses on being on six
soft ball teams right now,
literally can make 127,000
dollars a year in ad revenue
and live events and a
couple other sponsorships
and selling a couple t-shirts
by literally becoming
the authority on softball
in America.
- My son who is a junior in high school
is spending a good piece of his summer,
including right now, today
at a university in
Connecticut studying computer,
computer science, specifically
focused on video game design.
- Yeah.
- Just to back up video playing.
- Video game culture in 19--
When we were kids.
To think it was a mass industry.
I mean E-Sport's gonna
be bigger than baseball
in this country in 20 years.
E-Sport's is gonna be a bigger business
than major league baseball
in 20, 30 years from now.
I'll go 30, I'm gonna hedge a little bit.
In 30 years from now.
I mean, that is incredible to me.
India.
- [Voiceover] Atiyya asks,
"If you could swap out
one quality of your won
"for one of Casey's, and vice
versa, what would it be?"
- Mine's very easy.
I don't know if you know me well enough
to answer this question
but mine's very easy.
I'm a wimp when it
comes to physical stuff.
I don't ride skateboards.
I don't surf or ski.
I do very little risk
adventure.
I look at GoPro's, I'm like,
who gives a rat's ass?
Like that's not even in
my consideration set.
You know, one time jumped
off a 50 foot cliff
in Jamaica, I still
can't believe I did that.
(laughs)
Because there was a lot of chicks there.
Stuff was like peer
pressure, college stuff.
I mean, like fuck it,
everybody jumped too.
Some like eight year old jumped,
like all right (laughs).
So, having a little bit
of an adventurous bone
would be intriguing to me.
I mean look, I'm super happy the way I am
but if I have to answer the question,
having a little bit of
that free spiritedness
I think is really attractive to me.
- I'm gonna go really specific here, Gary
and that's your taste in and eye for wine.
You know, I am an uneducated kid
from a lower middle class house.
Yet, I present myself as someone
who's fairly sophisticated.
But when it comes to wine
which all conversations
in this world lead to wine,
(laughs)
I couldn't tell you
which one came from a box
and which one came from Gary's cellar.
And that's something I really appreciate
that you treat like an art form, Gary.
- I have a feeling we're gonna have video
maybe in a, I think in
12 to 18 months from now
we are gonna have to
drink very high end wine
while jumping out of a plane or something.
We're just gonna combine this--
- I hope not in that order.
- No, no, in that order.
We're gonna be really--
We may forget the parachute out.
It'll be big news.
We'll probably get the most
press we've ever gotten.
- That's true.
- You know, we're gone.
- Great YouTube video.
- We just drank too much wine,
forget to pull the cord.
- Lot of clicks, yeah.
Before we end this video.
- Yes?
- You're looking buff, man.
- Crazy right?
- Yeah, you're getting jacked, huh?
- It's happening.
- Yeah, big time.
But you, I mean look at this.
Give them something, give them something.
Give 'em a little--
- Ah, you're making me shy.
It's just this is because I have to carry
this big ass camera around all the time.
That's the only reason why
I have the physique I have.
It's to support my career.
- Case, the guest always gets
to ask the question of the day
What question?
I know you're ready, you had
to pull one out the last time.
Don't repeat it.
You were trying to recall what it was,
so I'm buying you some time.
Anything you'd like, fire away.
- That I ask the audience?
- Mm-hm, and they're gonna
answer in the comment section.
- Okay, how about something broad?
Which is,
Give us some generic advice
for how we could be better
communicators to you.
Gary and I both have
- [Gary] I like that.
this platform that we've built,
but we have this big platform
that's a huge loudspeaker
that we can speak to a lot of people from.
What is it that we
don't talk about enough?
What is that we should be sharing more of
that could have a great impact?
- Or how?
- Yeah.
- That stuff we hear and we appreciate.
This was great.
- Thanks for being on the show.
- Yeah, of course, any time.
- Yeah.
I'll save it for the next one.
You keep asking questions,
We'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)